[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL: Today I have--
[CLEARING THROAT]
Oh.
Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, Paul.
PAUL: We're welcoming
in the "Supercharged."
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's the
holidays here on "The Dev
Show," so I'm traveling
around the world-- hanging out
with friends and family
talking about developer stuff.
PAUL: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
are your tips for ways
they could spend their time?
PAUL: That's a good
question, first of all.
And I did have time
to think this through.
We have a browser rendering
optimization course
that you can do on Udacity,
which is well worth your time.
The second thing would be to go
and see the Chrome Dev Summit
playlists on YouTube.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great playlist.
PAUL: And then last
but not least, just
spend some time with the tools.
Maybe put your site
through WebPageTest.
We do this a lot on
"Supercharged" anyway,
so there's videos there you
could watch to see how we do it
and what we're looking for.
And just give it a try.
Even if you've just
got 20 minutes,
put your site through
it, see how it comes out.
And then you maybe sort of learn
one or two things and be like,
hey, you know what, in January
I'm going to fix that thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Those are great tips for
the developer in need.
PAUL: It's almost like
I had advance warning
of your arrival.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Paul.
I gotta go catch a bus,
so I'll see you later.
PAUL: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And on the
show today, Rich Hyndman.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey, Timothy.
How you doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
doing well, how are you?
RICH HYNDMAN: It's great
to see you over here.
You're the jet-lagged
one this time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
Here we are in London.
RICH HYNDMAN: On a bus.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: On a London bus.
RICH HYNDMAN: 55 to Hackney.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
a rather smooth ride.
There's things that we like
to do over the holiday breaks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mhm.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What is it you're
going to do with
your holiday break
to learn something
new about Android?
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
So when you're not
working on your work app,
you can work on
your personal app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
RICH HYNDMAN: I sit
near Nick Butcher,
and he's been working on the
Plaid sample application.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah?
RICH HYNDMAN: And
it looks amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Does it?
RICH HYNDMAN: Every time
you turn around, there's
a different animation.
He's been working on the
design for it very, very
hard over the last six months.
So I'm going to check that
out-- literally check it out--
and have a look through
his source code--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: --along with Ben
Weiss's Topeka application.
Very similar in terms
of material design,
lots of animations, very fresh.
Figure out how they put
that magic in there,
and maybe take some
of it for my app.
So I also want to check
out some people's videos
from throughout the year.
I think I need to have a
little look into Kotlin.
People talk about Kotlin
a lot, and Jack Wharton
gave a good talk about
it at Droidcon London.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: Definitely
Android Dev Summit videos,
if people haven't seen
them yet, as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: January, as we
found out on our previous show,
is the Black Friday for apps.
What are a few top
things developers
can do to get their app ready
for that big download period?
RICH HYNDMAN: Lots
of phones being sold
and lots of apps
being downloaded.
I think the first thing
to check, of course,
is always your
Play Store listing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, because
you can optimize that stuff.
There's tools in the console.
RICH HYNDMAN: You can do
not only the A/B testing,
but also it gives
you hints and tips
on things that you could
do to improve your chances.
Doesn't sound very relaxing,
but it's a good thing
to do this holiday season.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Sounds important.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well
at the same time,
you might as well do
some unit tests then,
keep the stability of
your application up.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: Because now
we're having real fun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
give us one last thing.
We've got Play Store listing,
unit testing-- analytics?
RICH HYNDMAN: Analytics
sounds like a good idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: You could do that.
Because everyone
always wants to analyze
the performance of
their application,
but they always forget
to put the analytics
in their personal apps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is a time when nobody's
looking that you could
just kind of put some
of those analytics in and--
RICH HYNDMAN: Everyone's
gonna have a great holiday.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Or just
check out the videos
that Rich was also checking out.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Android Dev Summit videos.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Thanks, Rich.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers, Timothy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]